all right let's check this out the new
york times says fed sending tactical
team to seattle expanding presence
beyond portland
after outrage of the presence of federal
agents in portland oregon
the trump administration is sending a
team to seattle officials say they will
be on standby
i bet this means a whole lot of nothing
will happen yep all right they say the
special response team being deployed
is similar to the tactical teams
currently operating in portland oregon
where local officials have been
vehemently objected to their efforts to
subdue street protests
come on man let's stop playing these
games protests
they declared a riot yesterday the the
portland police said it was a riot can
you please just call it a riot
who gets to decide that whatever seattle
officials have also said they do not
want federal agents sent to target
protesters
okay that's no i agree i would not want
federal agent target protesters either
agreed yeah
if you're out there protesting you have
my 100 support i think we all agree
absolutely now if you're rioting send in
the feds
agents from the srt operated under the
u.s customs and border protection agency
are typically deployed for intense law
enforcement operations
similar to the agency's bortek group
that has operated in portland
the cbp team will be on standby in the
area should they be required
the fp the federal protective service
said in a statement about this uh the
seattle effort
a spokesperson for the agency requested
anonymity to speak about the operation
so the border officers were sent back up
to uh sent to back up the fps
charged with protecting federal
buildings and would only be used if
protests expected this weekend escalate
out of control
and they will yeah seattle's mayor jenny
durkin said in an interview that she
spoke earlier with chad wolfe the acting
secretary of homeland security
she said he had assured her that the
administration had no plans to deploy a
surge of agents to seattle and would not
do so without communicating to the city
with the city she had not been alerted
to plans to position the tactical team
but said that the department may be
distinguishing between an active
deployment and agents who are on standby
now why do you think they're going to be
sending uh uh
this special response team up to seattle
because the powers that that are in
control over there are
very quickly losing control they're
doing nothing
that's awesome same as like what we're
seeing in portland but but hold on hold
on
it's not so simple to say that at least
i don't think so okay
take a look at this story from the
washington post 12 officers
injured two protesters arrested in
seattle as multiple businesses
vandalized whoa
whoa whoa whoa so wait they were they
were protesting
while vandalizing and destroying
business well they're rioting but hold
on hold on a minute you mean to tell me
that in seattle right now
these these violent thugs are going
around
destroying private property i will not
stand for that certainly that must be
the reason that trump is now sending in
the the special response team no that's
not it either
you want to know you want to see what it
is oh please please show you what it is
because this is from yesterday seattle
city council president addresses
protests targeting council members
houses okay i'm kidding i don't think
trump is actually sending in federal
agents
because the protesters are showing up to
politicians homes
but i do think it's kind of hilarious
that the chads
the capitol hill autonomous zone in
seattle can operate even with people
literally being
shot several times and the mayor's like
well you know hold on it could be a
summer of love bang bang some people die
and then well hold on
then they show up to the mayor's house
and then all of a sudden she's like
and she's demanding charges for the
councilman that led the protesters to
her house
and then chaz was purged with an iron
fist
yeah they cleaned it up in under an hour
yep actually
it was like it was like 10 minutes
everyone was gone
and then they spent the rest of the hour
just like disassembling fences and stuff
she's like the mayor jenny durkin has
like got her hands behind her back in in
her like uh
her study with there's books all around
her and they're like mayor durkin
they've shut up to your home you bite
the hen that feeds you
crash them and then like she hits a
button and then like a bunch of cops
like run out of her you know out of a
garage like the door opens up and then
they wipe that chas out so boom like
that so i think
they were working together it was all
just a trap to blame trump
what what i mean she was letting it
happen in my opinion no she was
because she wanted to be like come on
trump take the bait and he didn't do it
so then when they show up to her house
she was like no and she crushed them
the bait's starting to bite me think
about how easily how easily she crushed
the chas
as soon as they went to her house she
probably i swear she probably slammed
her face on the table
crush them and then they did yep now
look at what's happening in seattle
this uh it's in the same city obviously
but you have this uh
this woman i don't know her name is
sawant or whatever she's on the city
council and she's leading the protesters
to the homes
of other i don't want to show the photo
because it'll it
it's like they vandalized the door they
they wrote you know swears and stuff
saying like get the f out and stuff like
that
you know it's graffiti on this on these
people's home yeah
and i guess their addresses are private
but they were led there
by this councilwoman and so you also
have in oakland they actually show up to
the mayor's house and totally vandalized
it firing launching fireworks at it
so sure enough these people are
desperately crossing their fingers that
trump will
you know send in law enforcement because
they want to make them look bad
i think trump's winning i think so too i
think so
uh we actually actually i'm just gonna
show this right now i'm gonna show this
right now
so check this out this is civ iqs
and it is a of registered voters black
lives matter do you support or oppose
the black lives matter movement
and opposition to black lives matter has
been
spiking since the start of the riots and
people who consider themselves neither
in supportive or opposition 2
has gone down dramatically what does
that mean fence
sitters have gotten off the fence and
joined the opposition
yeah the interesting thing about it as
to why i think trump is winning is this
metric right here
race check this out among white people
it is now inverted for a minute white
people actually supported black lives
matter
substantial support since the riots it's
flipped
in favor of uh the opposition well
because it's becoming more and more
apparent that it's not about black lives
matter it's about
the whatever narrative that they're
pushing because you know
people are seeing that there's black
lives that don't matter to them
and black lives only specific black
lives matter to them and that doesn't
make any sense
yeah you're not gonna you're not gonna
see them cheering for jessie lee
peterson or candice owens
or hodge twins or terrence williams no
no they're they're the wrong thinkers
and it's like they're trying to convince
us and vince
to convince most people that they you
don't you don't
believe this so i need to scream it at
you for you to believe in it's like wait
what are you talking about like you know
of course we believe it of course we bel
we think black lives matter duh yeah of
course you know what i find funny
that like proves it's not about race or
even
orientation or identity is that you
literally have
trans trump supporters and black trump
supporters and latino trump supporters
exactly you have you have you know gays
for trump you have
uh latinos for trump you have blacks for
trump they're they're the
the republicans are really trying to to
you know
build a coalition a diverse coalition
yeah not that they're as
as successful as democrats because
democrats for whatever reason just
you know have historically controlled
votes in certain areas
that's why kanye west comes out and says
like yeah you know i i think it has a
lot to do with
social pressure thinking that they're
guaranteed and now joe biden comes out
you know the thing about what joe biden
said when he was like if you if you
don't know who you're for you know you
ain't black
i think he thought you know look in 2012
that would have played
that would have worked they would have
all laughed and be like you're right joe
biden
but he doesn't understand that today
that no way man like
there's a lot there's a lot of support
for trump in the african-american
community charlemagne just came out
against him today i didn't read an
article but i saw it in passing and i
was like oh wow like he started snapping
on biden i want to get into what he was
saying but
so so anyway donald trump is deploying
these law enforcement officers around
the country
yeah and you know you know we should
have pulled up the uh the cato institute
thing we did the other day oh yeah
but this uh this poll from the cato
institute shows there is only
one political alignment in this country
that is comfortable expressing their
opinions and it's the far left
yep they say strong liberal so i'll say
strong liberal
among strong conservative conservative
moderates
and liberals they are all scared to say
their opinions
all of them that's because they're all
voting for trump
or or they're critical of black lives
matter yeah
so so why is donald trump deploying law
enforcement
even though the media is screaming trump
is a
is a cheeto dictator it's because one
faction of people speaking up does not
represent the entirety of the country
exactly and so if liberals are scared to
speak up he's probably going to grab a
decent amount of liberals who are going
to be like please just shut it down
moderates absolutely and conservatives
are conservatives of course
they love trump yeah so you take a look
i brought this up earlier take a look at
what happened in chicago in june i think
june 8th
with all the riding so you look at this
and you can see that when once the
riding started
opposition started skyrocketing among
white people
and then i remembered that article where
uh it was a leaked recording
where an alderman in chicago it's like a
neighborhood mayor essentially
talks to the actual mayor of chicago and
was cussing her out
saying like they're coming the riots are
coming to our neighborhood stop them
stop them
and now the craziest thing is that you
literally have the neighborhoods begging
to stop the rioting yep
and the mayor says no and trump said yes
trump
knows who he's supporting he knows who
he's targeting yeah the american people
that's who he's supporting
he's supporting residential
neighborhoods not the business interests
not the downtown areas
and not the one faction of people who
think they're allowed to speak or the
establishment uh
governmental you know circles which
could be democrats and republicans
no one's you know everyone everyone
could be in that circle you know and
he's just saying
no we gotta we gotta protect the
american public that's why operation
legend was so i was just like yes
because he wasn't talking about who's to
blame he was just talking about
protecting
the american people that are getting
hurt by all this right now
i think they i think they made a big
mistake thanks for checking out this
clip from the tim cast irl podcast we do
the show live
monday through friday at 8 pm if you
want to catch the full show
tune in to this channel subscribe hit
the like button or
check us out on itunes and spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free
on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode
you